pick your poison play spin the bottle
with everyone in your immediate family
or b swallow a used condom you found on
a sidewalk
you said these are real things i'm not
making this up yeah yeah yeah these are
real things this is a real
game jesus christ
they spin the bottle with my immediate
family immediate family
swallow a used condom that you found on
the sidewalk
how many is it i'm trying to think
a spinner bottle can just go and go
because right i was i'm okay
if it's one spin and whoever it lands on
her lips
i just imagine it landed on my dad
it has to be a french as well
has to be a french lips i'll swallow the
knot i think
from the picture i just had of me lips
in my dad
nah i'll swallow the condom fam
roadside roadside just this uh um
because it's the same thing that i said
before it's just like i can tell my
brain that's a dare
that's a dare just get on with it it's
disgusting and i'll vomit
but there's no psychological trauma lips
in my dad
tongue everything lip suck
just that connective saliva oh nah
i don't think i bet my dad's tongue is
stronger than mine do what i mean
i've always listened what i've always
loved is women
that's so true as well that's so true i
was thinking which [ __ ] do you mean
i've only lived women yeah yeah and the
tongue is gentle
it's feminine it's gentle it's soft
they'd not be working out they're gonna
be working out of that
the ability's tongue is strong and wide
oh why that terry crews on white chicks
that clam tongue nah that could never be
in my mouth
now i'm supposed to massage it with my
tongue nah
run me the corner muscle or two oh fam
i'll swallow two oh
i'm not doing that i'm not doing that
oh that's disgusting
i know his tongue is strong oh that's
hilarious that is hilarious
um i would have my immediate family
would just literally be my mom my dad
and my sister
i would have to swallow the condom i
would have to
i would have to i would have to i
wouldn't like it i wouldn't enjoy it i
wouldn't wish it on my worst enemy i
wouldn't wish it on you
but i'd have to because i couldn't
lip-stop my family
not like that not like that if it was
not like that
quick oh yeah kissed on the cheek or
even a kiss on the lips
yeah i'm not swallowing johnny for that
i will kiss
i'll get strong
[Laughter]
that's different that's different energy
i'm not
nah nah you'd have to be there it's
disgusting